comme tous ses collègues d'habitude
karim derambure ne roule pas le 8 mai
mais aujourd'hui à 15 heures ils étaient
prêts à partir pour son 2ème trajet de
la journée fut partie à 4 heures ce
matin de paris je suis arrivé au dépôt
ce matin à 9 heures j'ai vidé mon camion
remorque que je les recharger et là j'ai
fait ma coupure à la maison et je
descends à grenoble pour la fin de
journée
ça fait un beau programme pour un jour
férié d'habitude vous travaillez jamais
vous en pensez quoi
bon ça me semble change pas grand chose
j'ai l'habitude de travailler donc ça me
semble changer ça ne change rien
comme karim deux autres chauffeurs de
cette entreprise ont pris la route et
pour leurs employeurs cette autorisation
exceptionnelle de circuler était plutôt
la bienvenue la semaine dernière on a eu
un jour férié donc ça fait trois ans de
semaine et quand on voit les capacités
des flux de transport bas trois jours ne
peut pas rouler à un moment donné ça
coince vraiment beaucoup dit moi j'ai
six plaintes à vivre les camions de
mario curiel sont sortis aussi est lui
aussi apprécié la levée d'interdiction
même si celui mais n'a pas pu être une
journée de travail normale s'est pas
aussi bien qu'on pourrait penser
maintenant aujourd'hui on n'arrive pas à
couvrir on va courir la route
on va éviter les chauffeurs est
immobilisée sur le sur des parkings mais
derrière le problème c'est que les
industriels travaillent port est trouvé
porte close à l'arrivée pas question
pour roland bretton qui a profité du
jour férié pour bichonner ses camions
lui aurait préféré ou les jeudis
d'autant plus qu'il ya beaucoup
d'industriels qui voit tout vert alors
que les camions ne rompt pas le droit de
rouler donc là on a un peu inversé les
choses
le i mais il n'y a pas de l'industrie
ouverte
et puis le jeudi sera la verse des
images comme celles-là le jour de
l'ascension on n'enverra plus sauf
dérogation spéciale tous les camions
seront bien à l'arrêt